fue la primera ciudad importante en caer
ante las fuerzas rusas y ahora ucrania
dice que se ha alcanzado un punto de
inflexión en la región de gerzón durante
el fin de semana el presidente ucraniano
dijo que sus tropas estaban avanzando
paso a paso hacia la ciudad un
sentimiento que llegó a los soldados en
terreno
liberaremos gerson esto es seguro yo no
lo entregaremos a los rusos por eso
estamos aquí para que nuestros hijos no
tengan que luchar más para que podamos
resolver este asunto ahora y para
siempre voy a volver son
estos soldados ucranianos están luchando
para retomar sección y aunque por ahora
son capaces de mantener sus posiciones
son conscientes de que necesitarán más
armas antes de lanzar cualquier
contraofensiva
hundió tu hijo otra vez como si
realmente no tenemos suficiente
artillería aquí si le disparamos ocho
veces nos devuelven el fuego 48 veces
por ahora tienen superioridad en
artillería gestión en las últimas
semanas las tropas ucranianas han ido
recuperando poco a poco territorio en
gerson con la ayuda de armas
occidentales ucrania afirma haber
atacado depósitos de armas rusos en los
alrededores de la ciudad y haber
destruido tres puentes clave aunque
rusia niega que se vaya a producir una
contraofensiva los servicios de
inteligencia occidentales muestran que
las posiciones defensivas de moscú se
están reforzando